[Music]
hello I know we've had our differences
in peace I don't want to see your face
anymore that you want to see mom we're
all in danger now from you know we have
a truce this is not how a truce were
just say what you gotta say red we've
discovered that there's a third island
and they're plotting to destroy us all
for the pilot give me one good reason
why I should believe you
I'll show you the proof will Team six
[Music]
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated cars who kind of saved
the whole island anyway war with Leonard
in the pigs what are you gonna do I'm a
foodie still going on those what and BOM
and Chuck are doing whatever they do I
eat dirt and me well I still have some
anger issues
but I'm finding healthier ways to deal
with it Fred I know we've had our
differences but we've discovered that
there's a third island maybe one good
reason why I should believe you now show
you the proof will team say really the
Pettis is a hundred times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver I just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing
what we'll break in and deactivate the
weapon we look amazing we gotta get that
key card hello fellow Eagle God how he's
doing a voice yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]